do you want to learn about multi-omics  data analysis techniques  sign up on omixlogiclearn and do real  research projects and cutting-edge  discoveries in these specialization  areas  not only this but also explore the ml  based t bioinfo server developed by  trobar bioinformatics research center  and learn data science for life science  of the 21st century become a part of a  global community and also get started  with your own research projects in the  specialization tracks mentioned on  omixlogic learn portal well what are you  waiting for sign up now and get started  with multi-omics training and data  science  also for any questions please feel free  to contact us on the given details here